what is going on everybody welcome to
another python 3 tutorial video in this
video we're going to be talking about is
the python standard library so the last
video we're talking about built-in
functions now we're going to be talking
about these modules that come with your
installation of python the first one
we're going to cover is os
and the purpose for os at least for my
uses has always been just any sort of
directory operation so
um changing your path
as far as you know where things are at
the moment making directories or folders
deleting them moving them around and so
on so let's go ahead and get started
with some examples of our os function
so first we're gonna need to import os
and then what we can do is we can figure
out first of all where are we so we can
say curder
equals o s.get cwd empty parameters
and what cwd stands for is current
working directory
and we can go ahead and print
cur dir like so save and run that and we
get where we are at the moment so for me
that's c users h desktop desktop syntax
lessons python3 say harrison
why do you have two desktops that's
funky
well uh i like a nice clean desktop so i
actually on my desktop have a folder
called desktop and i just move all my
desktop icons into that
yes i know you can hide
uh icons on your desktop
there's a reason why i don't do that but
that's not what this video is about so
anyway moving on
uh so closing out of that
so that's our current uh current
directory now
one of the other things we can do is we
can create directories so we can do os
dot mkdir for make dirt and we're going
to call this directory neuter
new dirt
and that's going to go basically right
up here as we make it so let's go ahead
and save and run that real quick
hopefully pop over here fast enough
there is our new directory as it just
popped up
now what we can do is we can close out
of this and come back down here and in
fact let's delete this one so it doesn't
get in our way as we run through this
now we can do is we could
let's make some time operations because
otherwise this whole thing might happen
faster than we see it with our eyeballs
so we're gonna import time we're gonna
say time.sleep
uh
two seconds
and we're gonna say os dot rename and
here we can rename a directory and we're
gonna rename nuder
and we're gonna call it
new dir two
now um
let's go ahead and run this
come over here there's neuter and then
wait for it there's new deer two
okay so we can close out of this awesome
let's delete neuter two
let's do another time dot sleep uh two
seconds
and this time let's make some space here
this time let us go ahead and remove the
dirt so os dot
rm dirt for remover
and now we specify the name that we want
to delete neuter two
uh so it's gone so okay let's save and
run it again
yep
and so there's new der
we rename it to neuter two and then a
couple seconds we delete it gone okay so
that's how we can do some of the file
operations uh you can also move
directories all kinds of fun stuff um
one of the things that we could do is
check this out
actually hold on let me do let's just
run this one more time
current working directory makes a
directory deletes that directory
should have os actually already imported
help
os
whoa
crazy so if you want to learn more of
the things about os we can use what we
just learned in the previous video as
you can see there is a lot of
information here
um
yeah just gobs of information that you
can do uh and use with os
so yeah
anyway gonna close out of that so that's
gonna conclude my tutorial on os again
there there's a huge amount of things
that you can do with os
um but for the most part people are
using os just to make directories remove
directories move directories uh or
delete directories i guess that was
remove directories
uh rename directories that's the other
thing i was looking for
so anyway a quick tutorial on os the
next tutorial we're going to cover is
for system
and system actually is quite fun you can
do some really neat kind of hacky things
with sys so
that's the next thing we'll be showing
so stay tuned for that if you have any
questions or comments on this video feel
free to leave them below if you have any
requests
also feel free to make requests i'm
making the series right now as we as you
listen
so if you have a specific request make
it and it'll probably find its way into
this series
anyway that's it with this stay tuned
for the next video as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions and until next time